aquí a la izquierda se encuentra la
gráfica de f que tiene una tangente
vertical en el punto 30 aunque nos vamos
al punto 30 y aquí la gráfica f tiene
una tangente vertical vamos a dibujarla
aquí tiene una tangente vertical y
también tiene una tangente horizontal en
los puntos 0 - 3 nos vamos al 0 - 3 aquí
tiene una tangente horizontal y también
tiene una tangente horizontal en el
punto 6 363 aquí tiene otra tangente
horizontal y lo que tenemos que hacer es
seleccionar todos los valores de x para
los cuales f no es diferenciable de
todas estas opciones tenemos que
seleccionar las que apliquen pero a ver
pensemos en esto queremos buscar todos
los puntos de x para los cuales f no es
diferenciable osea estamos buscando los
puntos de x para los cuales no
existe efe prima y esto puede suceder
por tres razones distintas la primera
condición que nos dice que no existe la
derivada de f en un punto es que
tengamos una tangente vertical como aquí
tangente tangente vertical y porque si
tenemos una tangente vertical no se
puede definir la derivada de f bueno
pues recuerda que con la derivada lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar la tasa de
cambio de ye con respecto a x pero si
tenemos una tangente vertical con el más
ligero cambio en el eje de las x tenemos
una cantidad infinita de cambio en el
eje de la yes ya sea en el sentido
positivo o negativo así es que esta es
una situación en la que no tenemos f
prima y bueno por acá nos dicen
exactamente en donde tenemos una
tangente vertical en el punto 30 o sea
cuando x es igual a 3
en esta opción no tenemos derivada de f
porque tenemos esta tangente vertical y
bueno tal vez en este momento tú me
preguntes oye pero qué pasa con las
tangentes horizontales pero con las
tangentes horizontales no tenemos ni un
solo problema las tangentes horizontales
son sólo lugares donde la derivada es
igual a cero así es que por aquí efe
prima de 6 es igual a 0 y f prima de 0
es igual a 0 pero regresando a la
pregunta cuáles son los otros escenarios
donde f no es diferenciable bueno
tenemos un segundo escenario que es
cuando la función no es continua no
continua y por acá en la gráfica de f
podemos ver que cuando x es igual a
menos 3
no es continua así es que por aquí efe
no es diferenciable en x menos 3
efe no es diferenciable y bueno estos
son los únicos lugares que nos han dicho
en esta gráfica que f no es
diferenciable la verdad no sabemos cómo
se comporta la función de este lado ni
de este otro seguramente estos dos son
casos muy interesantes pero ninguno de
los dos casos está dentro de las
opciones que podemos escoger por otro
lado acerca de esta opción ya la
analizamos ya dijimos que aquí la
derivada de 0 y cuando x es igual a 6
también sabemos que es diferenciable
porque su derivada de 0 porque tenemos
aquí una tangente horizontal y bueno nos
falta un último escenario en el que una
función pueden no ser diferenciable el
tercer escenario sucede cuando tenemos
una curva cerrada
esta no es una definición precisamente
matemática es un término bastante
coloquial ya lo que me refiero con esto
es cuando tenemos picos por ejemplo
cuando tenemos una función así o cuando
tenemos una función así porque lo que
sucede aquí es que del lado izquierdo
tenemos cierta pendiente conforme nos
acercamos al pico pero del lado derecho
tenemos otra pendiente por lo tanto el
límite por la izquierda de la pendiente
va a ser distinto al límite por la
derecha de la pendiente por lo que es el
límite no existe porque es distinto del
lado izquierdo que del derecho pero
bueno en este ejemplo yo no veo ninguna
curva cerrada así es que esto no aplica
para este ejemplo bueno ahora vamos con
otro ejemplo y este ejemplo si tiene una
curva cerrada así es que va a ser un
ejemplo muy interesante a la izquierda
se encuentra la gráfica de la función f
tiene una cinta vertical cuando x es
igual a menos 3 definitivamente la
podemos ver por acá
tiene un asiento está horizontal cuando
oye es igual a 0 a ver
0 si definitivamente por acá este pedazo
de la gráfica parece que se acerca cada
vez más a 0 conforme x tiende a menos
infinito y tiene otra asín tota
horizontal cuando ya es igual a 4 ya
igual a 4 si también parece que conforme
x tiende a infinito esta parte de la
gráfica se acerca cada vez más a 4 ahora
selecciona todos los valores de x para
los cuales f
no es diferenciable bueno primero que
nada podemos pensar en las tangentes
verticales yo no veo ninguna no no hay
ninguna tangente vertical
luego nos ponemos a pensar en los
valores de x en los que la función no es
continua
efe definitivamente no es continua
cuando tenemos esta cinta vertical así
es que f no es continua cuando x es
igual a menos 3 - 3
tampoco es una función continua cuando x
es igual a 1
así es que aquí f tampoco es
diferenciable y luego la última
situación que habíamos visto para que
efe no fuera diferenciable es si
teníamos una curva cerrada que también
lo podríamos ver como un punto afilado
en nuestra gráfica o bueno un pico y
bueno yo veo uno de esos puntos por acá
y observa por acá del lado izquierdo del
punto si nos fijamos en la pendiente por
acá pareciera que tiene una pendiente de
no sé una pendiente de tres medios más o
menos pero si nos vamos a la derecha de
ese punto la pendiente ahora es negativa
así es que si tratáramos de encontrar el
límite de las pendientes conforme se
acercan a tres de los dos lados que es
justo lo que siempre hacemos cuando
encontramos la derivada en un punto
bueno pues es el límite no va a estar
definido porque va a ser distinto por la
izquierda que por la derecha
así es que f tampoco es diferenciable en
este punto en el punto que provoca este
pico esta curva cerrada
efe no es diferenciable en 3 y si
dibujamos la gráfica de la derivada de f
que lo vamos a hacer muchas veces en
otros vídeos veríamos que en este punto
la derivada de f no es continua pero
bueno regresando por acá ahora vamos a
checar si en x0 la función f es
diferenciable x igual a 0 y por aquí
este punto se ve bastante bien la recta
tangente definitivamente no se ve como
una recta vertical la función f es
continua en este punto y no tenemos
ningún pico ninguna curva cerrada como
la que teníamos por acá así es que
cuando x es igual a 0 efe si es
diferenciable